should we talk about the ACLU yeah sure
let's do it let's do this why not so the
American Civil Liberties Union I used to
be a big fan now they're basically just
the anti Civil Liberties Union and I'll
tell you why but first let me show you
this story this is from NBC News picked
up by Yahoo ACLU Sue's Betsy DeVos over
new campus sexual assault rules let's
read a little bit of the context
Education Secretary Betsy DeVos revised
federal guidelines and how sexual
assault allegations should be handled on
college and k12 campuses is the target
of a federal lawsuit filed Thursday
claiming the changes would inflict
significant harm on victims and
dramatically undermine their civil
rights the suit filed on behalf of for
advocacy groups for sexual assault
survivors including no year nine girls
for gender equity is the first at and
girls for gender equity is the first
that attempts to block the Department of
Education new provisions before they go
into effect on August 14th the rules
championed by DeVos effectively bolster
the rights of due process for those
accused of assault and harassment
allowing for live hearings and cross
examinations it's what agency officials
say was lacking under the Obama
administration to protect all students
under title 9 a 1972 law that prohibits
gender discrimination including sexual
assault at schools quote this new
federal effort effort to weaken title 9
makes it more difficult for victims of
harassment or sexual assault to continue
their education and needlessly comes
amid a global pandemic according to the
suit which was filed in US District
Court in Maryland by the American Civil
Liberties Union and the New York based
law firm struck and struck and Livan LLP
the suit names divorce the Education
Department and Kenneth Marcus the
agency's Assistant Secretary of Civil
Rights the department did not
immediately respond to a request for
comment about the complaint so let me
just stop right here and break this down
simply for you even NBC News says under
title 9 they needed more due process
live hearings and cross examinations
agency officials said this was lacking
why is the ACLU seeking seeking to take
away due process from the accused I I'm
kind of shocked this is something that
DeVos is I'm actually okay with I know
like Levin I agree with this so let me
give this this is good why are they
fighting it well it's
let me give you some context okay good
title 9 is an anti-discrimination
provision ok that's been used so
basically you know feminists have said
if a woman is assaulted or harassed then
it's unfair because the if the
universities don't go after these
individuals it's discrimination okay
what's ended up happening is a lot of
these universities don't care about due
process right they're not a legal court
so they operate under what's called the
preponderance of evidence if a woman
accuses you they ask you what happened
and if you say something like well we
were you know drinking and hanging out
at my apartment they'll say well good
enough for us yeah you admit you were
there and she said it happened you're
expelled due process would be I would
like to cross-examine a you know
confront my accuser the things that you
normally would get in in the court yeah
in underage class English common law hmm
you know with the Fifth Amendment we
have a right to a real due process that
doesn't exist Betsy DeVos is trying to
give the same rights at universities
that we get in a court of law that makes
I'm to a certain degree right okay well
it does if some woman comes out and says
this man assaulted me well do we destroy
his life on your word we need evidence
that literally happened to my friend
right yeah so Betsy DeVos wants to enact
these check these rule changes and
bolster the ACLU is arguing that
violates the civil rights of the women
now but think about the logic there that
doesn't make any sense it doesn't it
look me everyone has equal rights then
it's just equal rights
when's the ACLU gonna file suit to
abolish the Fifth Amendment then right
it's not fair that the accused get to
confront their accuser that's violating
their civil rights what so you can just
accuse and then that they just trust
that and throw a guy in prison they've
done it I know they have yeah yeah do
you know about like mattress girl yeah I
think we talked about Asoka wits yeah
and then she shifted right now she's
yeah right but apparently like when she
accused this guy there were text
messages showing that she was like no
like it was not true
what what she was saying she was begging
him she was messaging him for you know
for years saying I love you and stuff
like that and then it was like two years
later she accused him or something I'm
probably the details wrong but there are
a lot of questionable you know
storylines you know questionable bits of
evidence
so it would make sense that we make sure
we protect the innocent yeah exactly
yeah without these rules you're not
pertaining the innocent you empower
exploitation exactly why would the ACLU
since to oppose this I don't know that's
I can tell you why go ahead please
enlighten me so for those I think we may
have talked about the story but I'll
tell you guys the story
the ACLU famously defended the KKK in
Skokie Illinois we talked about some
recently a thing oh yeah yeah right
right and that was they were very much
liberal like we believed in the liberty
and freedom and we're gonna stand up for
the right to free speech I don't agree
with what you say but I'll defend to the
death your right to say it
okay and back then liberals cheered for
it you know that's why today the left is
no longer liberal easiest way to explain
it if anyone ever says to you that you
know they're liberals or whatever ask
him about defending the right to free
speech of the Klan yeah because that's
what liberals used to do as what they
still do the left today is not liberal
liberals have left and the ACLU has
abandoned all liberal principles for
money so the ACLU fought against Donald
Trump's travel ban okay he was you know
this man in the seven countries and they
immediately gained a whole bunch of
leftist donors it was it was a windfall
tell me how much cash they made when
they then defended the right to free
speech of unite the right in
charlottesville they got attacked for it
and immediately bent the knee saying
please don't take our money away yeah it
would be very upset if we lost our money
I got a taste of that yup
so now that the anti Civil Liberties
Union they don't defend free speech they
have backpedaled and now they're
actively seeking to take away civil
rights this ridiculous the anti Civil
Liberties Union it's gross man and it
bugs me out because I once I work for a
company where we fundraised for the ACLU
I was very proud yeah I was like do the
a sales a sale he's awesome I remember I
was in Chicago we were doing Street
canvassing okay and I said I was
fundraising to one guy and he was like a
parent like you stop people in the
street you wave like you know hey we so
we would ask him to have a minute to
talk about defending civil rights and a
lot of people would hear these stories
and then I remember talking to one guy
who said you know that like they very
famously defended the KKK who like came
up and they marched to a Jewish
neighborhood and I was like I absolutely
did know that and he was like you don't
care and I was like I don't like these
people yeah I don't like the message
they bring yeah I don't agree with what
they're saying but but we have a first
amendment this country and so you have
to recognize that
you know dictators love the idea that
they could infringe upon the rights of
one used as a pretext because I think it
take away the rights of all yeah and the
guy was like a completely agree he's
like I love what they do
yeah man I wonder what what these you
know old-school liberals think now and
how many of them sold their values out
yeah think about like you know I was
talking to somebody last I think was
like a year two ago about this shift
mm-hmm and I was told that employees
they're like the people who work there
like they know yeah they know they've
sold their souls they know it's gotten
bad they're no longer fighting for civil
rights I think that's the gist of the
story oh there's a little bit more let's
read a little bit more here just to give
that actually a lot more oh well well I
don't know I don't wanna get into too
much of the nitty-gritty because but
they say divorce last week denied that
the final rule would discourage victims
from coming forward to report abuse and
instead allows for schools to be more
balanced in how they review claims
rather than through what she called a
kangaroo court approach we can continue
to combat misconduct without abandoning
our core value of fairness presumption
of innocence and due process how schools
should address sexual assault comes amid
the larger me - movement focusing on
claims of misconduct that might
otherwise go ignored schools that fail
to adhere to title nine requirements
risk the loss of federal funding so I'll
tell you what man I think we all saw
where the me2 movement went and it was
predictable for a lot of people yeah the
moment it came out for a Biden
whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa
we didn't mean against us yeah thanks I
mean you know it's ridiculous now you
get vice-president creepy hands and they
they don't care
creepy hands man yeah this this is
something that we needed for my so I
mentioned my friend a lot of people are
making jokes about who my friend was I'm
just gonna tell the story like when I
was in high school one of my good
friends was dating this girl and he
broke up with her and it was just like
as people do they break up and like
three days later she was freaking out at
him in school like yelling at him you
know screamin like you know a most just
emotions and then she just claimed you
know a couple days after that that he
raped her and he went to prison for two
years and then after about like a year
and a half to two years later well while
he was in prison she she said to like a
doctor or someone that look I feel
really guilty I said this when I was
younger I was emotional I don't love him
anymore I don't feel the same way he
didn't rape me I was just mad at him and
it was like what and then the courts
found out and they released him and he
lost two years of his life because he
didn't there was no questions asked he
was just put in prison and they just
believed what she said and it was it's
ridiculous because this kind of thing
didn't exist and you also got to think
about what it looks like on a resume or
your life history when there's a
two-year gap exactly where were you I
was in prison for rape it's like how
does that look you know I was innocent
trust me
and he was he was innocent have you seen
them with that's not changing his record
have you seen them all it's probably
expunged who knows I don't know how it
works
have you seen the life of David gale
Kevin Spacey movie nonetheless true yeah
creepy I haven't seen in a long time I
know he's in prison or something no no
it's not I don't remember someone's in
jail guys the guys who accuse him
mysteriously died wait say it again the
guys who accused Kevin Spacey
mysteriously died okay I don't know was
it I don't I do not remember that movie
at all David Gill I don't I don't
remember it basically I've seen it but
he's an Amanda he's a it's a great movie
yeah I recommend it if you guys haven't
seen it okay he's an anti-death penalty
activist he goes to a party and there's
a he's a college professor and this
woman basically is like you know let's
hook up she says things like you know
harder harder scratch me and like tear
it off about her clothes and he does and
then she uses that against him to claim
that he raped her and it was because
apparently she was failing his class and
she tried to offer him you know sex in
exchange for a good grade he said no
okay so she accuses him his life has
immediately destroyed he's fired and you
can't get hired anywhere and then she
just leaves and so what ends up
happening is the assumption is that she
got scared and fled and he must be
guilty even though there was no
accusation no no proof no his life mm-hm
and so the long story short the movie is
about him he's on death row and he's
trying to explain the story of how he
ended up there and like you know this
other woman that he was working with how
she died it's a really really old movie
so I'm going to spoil a bit of it for
you but basically it destroyed his life
you know made him extremely
I guess suicidal and then he ended up
martyring himself for the cause to
resist the death penalty but it's
interesting how man the court of public
opinion
you could like your friend probably
dealt deals the ramifications of that
still to this day problem with SAT I
mean he has a wonderful family and a
wonderful job now and I'm really really
happy for him it's good and uh two years
so I mean but it still doesn't change
what happened to him yeah two years
that's a lot of time and they're gonna
be people who gone there there are
people who probably would believe you if
you if you went to prison for something
like this and then got released yeah you
know was proven you're innocent and
people are still gonna have in the back
of their minds yeah exactly so bill 'ti
oh yeah it's crazy that people assume if
you're being arrested you've got
something wrong you know that's scary I
agree I agree that's the world we live
in now though yeah yep I've seen so many
videos where the cops will be arresting
somebody mm-hmm
like you could put on a cop uniform and
just chase someone down and they will
help you that's how scary that's it's
it's a con-artist thing it's uh it's
it's you you it's the use of authority
for manipulation mm hm your if you look
like a cop you can be out you can be
having someone on the ground and they
can be screaming for help and no one
will have this person so if you were
like there's actually what criminals
encounters do to a certain degree they
use that view of authority think about
that mentality people have scale it up
to someone getting arrested doing a perp
walk and then the news being like and
I'm Craig Euler was arrested for you
know felony embezzlement II robbed you
know and it wasn't true and once he's in
the news they don't care it's true as
far as they're concerned you were
arrested for it therefore you know
that's why we always say we got it
innocent until proven guilty that's what
so happen to that the ACLU uh saw some
some green that's he's trying to bring
it back man yep this is the weirdest
thing you know I there are certain
cultural issues related to you know
conservatives religious issues in life
and choice kind of issues death penalty
issues they don't agree with but right
now when it comes to the Constitution
freedom the economy you've got bill Barr
challenging these states
unconstitutional efforts you got Betsy
DeVos trying to bring back you know due
process and I'm like these are not these
are and Rand Paul yeah good dude yeah
dude so Bernie Sanders didn't show up
for this vote what's up like that you
think he'd be on the forefront he could
have been the one
to end this spying abuse if he if he if
he showed up why what's up with that
that's Bernie got a lot of a sense I
don't like any of these people man
yeah but I'll individually support you
know people I think do a great job
it's funny that people you know want me
to like yellow I'm gonna vote for it's
like bro I know if a Rand Paul in two
seconds I don't even agree with him a
lot of issues but he's a man of
principle yeah he stand he stands up for
the rights of the people and I really
really should respect that you know
about him he's he's always on the side
of like the government shouldn't have
the power to do these things he's always
he's not perfect I'm sure there's some
things I can call him out for but I
think he's a good dude thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune into this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you